Joy to the world
The Lord is come
Let earth receive her King.
It's not because
the gays know theatre,
it's because the gays just
know how to do stuff.
You know?
I mean, they're survivors.
And for some reason they're
always obsessed with me.
I don't know why.
But I like it.
These gorgeous stars came
with the tree. I love them.
I do too.
Give.
He's going on a date.
-Like from Grindr?
-No.
Oh my god.
Jesus H Christ.
I know. I know.
No, that's the title
of my play.
Oh.
All the world's a stage
And most of us are
desperately under-rehearsed.
Who said that?
-Wasn't Shakespeare.
-Who?
I can't remember,
that's why I asked.
It could've been
Captain Kangaroo.
He was smart.
Try that.
No one's listening. Listen!
Listen!
But I just thought
everyone should know
that the pageant is a giant
load of crap on a stick.
And not in a good way
if you know what I mean.
Unless you look deeper,
there was nothing
particularly remarkable
about Mary.
Mary rode a donkey.
Mary liked camels
and donkeys.
And rode them both.
Nancy Michaelson, she just
came up to me and she said,
"Your show was so damn good
it needs to go on tour."
Congratulations, it really
was a great show, Sand.
You agree
that it should go on tour?
What?
-I don't know what to--
-Oh my god.
And you know what?
I think it should be
a national tour.
And this time, Ellen Greene
can be my understudy.
Be right back. Or not.
For I've been making eyes
with a very handsome man
and now it's time
to land the plane.